welcome to this video the thought game
of this batch yeah this batch of three
games almost played live just before I
uploaded and as mentioned in the first
video at a super bad run yesterday after
a long day at the office when I just
lost lost and lost and okay so I'm
trying to play a couple of games to keep
the the stream of videos steady um this
is the third game of this row and then
at least them I have some other opponent
now some other than Allah gas which own
I appreciate to to know that the
opponent will play any position on time
and so on its own not too great okay so
it's a night off um done a plate yeah
maybe slightly strange stuff I don't
know let's see what happens it's only at
least complicated I'm gonna plate here
with e 5 which is a bit uncommon against
the Bishop g5 lines let's see what
happens now I'm attacking SF for
threatening may be threatening to take
it until not quite sure what I should do
so very complicated maybe yeah this is a
possibility but I thought if I take the
Queen takes I have g5 them okay so i
can't play gt5 now leading to a very
strange position now Kane he's attacking
d6 um anyway yeah okay at least them
it's sufficiently weird
this disposition ok he will get F get d6
but how how bad is that actually 95-96
should be 6 26 mm rock t6 should be six
and then should be four at the end this
is this is a bit of a problem it's not a
very not a very safe square on e5
maybe I need to do the same ones got
this is God Bishop deform I can take the
form it looks at it looks like insanity
but okay if I spend any more time it's
also not helping okay 96 Bishop 36 takes
everything looked is six at the end and
then I take if for done is it's
dangerous but it should work at the end
I'm [ __ ] push up and look but he's
got their various moves this is one of
them so yeah Bishop e7 I Scott's about
95 oh haha okay so um I need to do
something else I take f5 and if it takes
f6 can I make a sec out of that giving
away giving away the look i have fun
porn at least yeah okay let's take it
and now Bishop Bishop somewhere I go to
g4 yes um as this night moves mighty
fine I probably need to go here so on Oh
I'm actually a rock down I'm a rope down
this is too much I of course it took f6
it was a piece yeah this was stupid yeah
this was very stupid okay yeah playing
chess games early in the morning as has
never been great for me but I simply
couldn't stand the idea to not upload
three games so um ok let's continue just
a couple of MU see if I can can get any
miracle going on the king I mean it's a
it's just it's just a rook really not
not the slightest hint of compensation I
get the ship on the long diagonal there
is a bit of something but how to however
to to get that I don't really see how no
Bishop somewhere here check at least
it's not it's not really much Bishop to
e5 you can also always play a queen to
go into before ok so that's a drop back
yeah queen before it's really occurring
b6 yeah tween b6 yeah this exchanges
does it
canford try to avoid the Queen trade
with Queen a form but of course it's
just busted I should resign yeah come on
I can I can't really resign that black
reason right yeah well playing chess in
the morning kingscrusher does it all the
time but I'm not the greatest ever to do
that all right so three games this
morning and I hope to be in in better
shape in the video some that will be
uploaded tomorrow morning trying to play
this well rested and not still
half-asleep burn in the evening today
yeah thanks for watching anyway